Before I extend my New Year's greetings to everyone,
I would like to offer my deepest condolences and pray for those who lost their lives in the Great Noto Earthquake.
My heart goes out to all those affected by the current disaster.
Once again, I would like to wish everyone a Happy New Year.
I am very happy to be able to hold a New Year's event with so many people for the first time in four years without any restrictions.
I'm sure the last three years have been tough for many people,
but I am convinced that it is our positivity and perseverance that has led us to where we are today.
I believe that we must continue our effort to follow in the spirit of the Founder's Aikido,
to help make society even a little more prosperous as much as possible.
The founder went to Hawaii for the first time in 1961, a little over 60 years ago,
and said that he was going with the intent of building a silver bridge and see the world with a spirit of harmony, and to contribute in making society as prosperous as possible.
I think we need to cherish that feeling and do our best to help society become that kind of prosperous society.
I think that what we can do is practice Aikido hard every day and try to get as close as possible to the founder's feelings.
I want to continue to practice hard this year and move forward.
I hope you all move forward with that same feeling.
In this New Year, I would like to express my faith in you. Thank you very much.